so how do we apply heat to food to cook
it
we start with fuel and we then take the
fuel and either burn it or use it in
some fashion in order to create heat and
that heat then transforms food from
being uncooked and rather unappetizing
to being cooked and rather delicious so
let's start to think about the process
of you know transferring heat to food
from fuel for a minute so it turns out
that that wood or any fuel has what we
call an energy density this is an energy
per unit mass I'm usually the way that
it's reported of how much energy can be
liberated by burning the fuel so in the
case of wood the energy density is 14
mega joules per kilogram that's 14
million joules per kilogram joules is a
unit of energy
it's an SI unit of energy its measured
in you know kilograms meters squared per
second squared and the end 14 mega
joules per kilogram is the energy
density of wood now it turns out the
charcoal has actually a much higher
energy than wood the energy density of
charcoal is about 30 mega joules per
kilogram so it's almost a factor of 2
more which for those of you who have
cooked on piles of charcoal this
explains why you need less of it really
to heat the same amount of food so
another way to cook food is not to burn
fuel at all but is to use an oven of
some sort and there are at least two
types of ovens there are you know you
know there are electrical ovens you know
which have hot coils on them which
actually heat the air within them and
there are microwave ovens which sends
radiation and that interacts with and
heats the food if you go look at the
specs on an oven it turns out it doesn't
report the energy in you know in terms
of the fuel that it's yours it actually
reports the energy and what are called
watts
now watts are watch as a unit of power
it's the units of watts are joules per
second and the point of that of course
is is that if you put the food in the
device for you know whatever period of
time then if you simply multiply the
power output of other times the time
that you put it in that's how much
energy you could hope to absorb by the
food if it's being done correctly
I mean suppose you were to take food and
put it in your oven for 10 minutes so
since every minute has 60
that's 600 seconds if your if your oven
has a thousand watts then that means
that the total energy of you can
possibly dump in to the food is a
thousand watts
times 600 seconds which is 600 thousand
which is 600 thousand joules which is
actually less than the you know than
what you would have in a kilogram of
wood when you and when you apply heat to
food what are you actually doing to it
what is heat anyway one definition is to
say that heat is the total energy the
results in the temperature of the system
being whatever it is so you sort of you
know high or temperature you know if you
have a thing with higher temperature
that means it has more heat so at a
molecular level and temperature is a
measure of the motion of the molecules
within a material so what's actually
happening is is that the molecules in a
material are jiggling around at some
rate you can just imagine them jiggling
and when you heat them up they jiggle
around faster and that's what
temperature is and it's this jiggling
that causes changes to occur the
material which is at the heart of what
we do when we cook and try to make food
delicious so a simple way to demonstrate
this to you is to just show you a
simulation so this is a simulation of a
material this is a simulation of water
molecules essentially in a box and
initially the water molecules are at a
rather low temperature and so they're
sitting barely moving at all and now
what we're going to do is gradually
raise the temperature in the simulation
and what you see is is that when the
temperatures that is sort of slightly
higher well the molecules start to
jiggle a little bit and they start to to
move and bump into each other a little
bit if we raise the temperature a little
more of the molecules start to move by
each other and when we raise temperature
a whole lot the whole thing comes apart
and you see the molecules whizzing
around everywhere and that whizzing of
the molecules the jiggling and the
whizzing is the essence of temperature
and that is what we're actually doing to
a material when we dump in heat